justified coming to an end
yeah I'm an I'm an unemployed in like
yeah yeah once again a pity party it's a
pity party here well how do you how do
you feel about that it must be emotional
because you've made these connections
with fellow cast members and there's
definitely things I'm gonna really miss
and no particular order free haircuts
right free haircuts right yeah I'm paid
for a haircut in years yeah it's awesome
it's great but it's been so it's been an
illness it's this has been a wonderful
job I mean six years really a whole cast
and crew six years not one real [ __ ]
you know really wait a minute you're
saying that because your show it's no
small thing it's show business
yeah but it's a lot of people on your
show you're constantly revolving
characters in and out you're saying of
all those people not on words it was a
jerk yeah like one like we had one or
two like douchebags you know look you
know that's not thing but not like major
[ __ ] that just ruins the whole tell
me I mean I've why I love after I watch
it who was it douche bag well you you uh
you met you met him he was on the show
you met him you call yeah I mean names
we're not gonna name names but the only
person from your show that's that I've
interviewed on this show is Patton
Oswalt
that's my bad let's not tell them good
yeah I'm sure the way is right guy great
I'll be just saying he was in character
I think a lot of times guy like that
he's deep in character you can't tap
okay you're hanging out of craft service
I didn't know yeah character okay I'm
gonna talk to him about this we're gonna
have him on to clear this up
you